[Caller] Hey Rob, Jeff calling
from Northern Virginia.
You've recommended other fantastic books.
Would really like to know,
what else you recommend?
Or can you come out
with a list on your show
of Rob Lowe must reads or your top 20?
I really look forward to that.
And again, just, I cannot tell
you what an experience I had
with "The Moon's a Balloon."
Thank you so much for everything.
Well, Jeff from Northern Virginia,
by the way, I love that
you're from Northern Virginia.
It's like you're in a civil
war battalion, I love that.
I'm from Northern Virginia.
That's great.
Thank you. I'm glad you
liked "The Moon's a Balloon."
It was my inspiration
for writing my two books.
So the Northern Virginia Civil War thing
made me think of one of my favorite books,
which is called "The Killer Angels."
And it is a book I believe
it won the Pulitzer Prize
and it is sort of the definitive account
of the Battle of Gettysburg.
And you don't have to be a historian
or a Civil War buff to
read it, nor should you be.
It's just the most beautifully
written, emotional,
very short books I've ever read.
So that's "The Killer Angels."
Another one I am loving is,
I believe it's called
"Under the Comanche Moon."
And I just heard that
Paul Thomas Anderson,
one of my favorite directors
has been secretly working
on the movie adaptation
of "Under a Comanche Moon."
So that is gonna be one of
the great movies of all time.
And there you have it. Thanks.
I love that.
I need to do like an Oprah's book
like recommendation thing.
Oprah, I'm coming for ya!
This is just the first version of it.
Look out, there's more to come.